[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEWITT CLINTON: Great.
Welcome.
Thanks, everyone, for coming.
My name's DeWitt.
RYAN GREGG: And my name is Ryan.
DEWITT CLINTON: And
we're product managers
on the Google Cloud team.
RYAN GREGG: Before
we get started today,
though, I wanted to sort of
poll the audience, mostly
because it's the afternoon
and we're probably
feeling a little sleepy.
So how many of you are running
Kubernetes in your organization
today, or planning to run it--
DEWITT CLINTON: Well--
RYAN GREGG: That's pretty good.
DEWITT CLINTON: We had
a really good joke.
And I was going to say,
you, with your hand down,
wait six months.
You're going to put it up.
But I don't think we
get to use that joke.
RYAN GREGG: And
then how many of you
are running serverless today,
or using a serverless platform?
Good.
You all came to the right place.
DEWITT CLINTON: All right.
Well, this is going
to be exciting.
So today we are going to
talk about two things we
know you're all excited about--
that's Kubernetes
and serverless.
And we know that because
you just put your hands up.
And the talk is called
"Kubernetes, Serverless,
and You."
And you came.
But, also, we're going to
introduce two new things
that you're just
learning about today.
One is the serverless add-on
for Google Kubernetes Engine.
And the other is
Knative, the open source
project that powers it.
And a lot of people worked
very, very hard on this.
And we're going to try
our best to do it justice.
But if we trip up, just
applaud really loud right then.
So let's get started.
So this is all possible
thanks to Kubernetes.
So, as you know, Kubernetes is
the open source orchestration
layer for managing and
deploying containers.
Announced only four years
ago, Kubernetes is now
supported by every major cloud.
It has taken off like wildfire.
Every day, thousands
of people contribute
to the success of Kubernetes,
allowing real businesses
like yours to abstract away
the underlying infrastructure.
And, in fact, it's that power of
abstracting away the underlying
infrastructure that has allowed
us to think of infrastructure
as a smooth, paved surface,
available wherever you are,
in your data center or in ours.
But that's only half the story.
RYAN GREGG: The other half
of the story for today
is serverless, which
is fundamentally
changing the way that developers
approach building applications.
Some of you in the industry
may think of serverless
as only meaning functions.
But there's so much more to
the promise of serverless
than just running snippets
of code in the cloud.
In fact, we at Google see
serverless not just as compute,
but as the whole stack
that allows developers
to focus on what really matters,
that core nugget of business
value, and not have
to be concerned
with the complexities of
the infrastructure that
runs that code.
In fact, Google has been
working on serverless
for more than a decade.
10 years ago-- almost exactly--
was it April, I guess?--
we launched App Engine,
the very first platform
as a service, and the very first
Google cloud-- or, sorry, one
of the first platforms of
service, and the very first
Google Cloud product.
Since that time, over
the last 10 years,
we've continued to
innovate, providing
a number of additional
serverless solutions.
And today we were
very happy to announce
the general availability
of Cloud Functions.
[APPLAUSE]
That is super exciting.
But there's so much
more to serverless.
This is just a journey
that's still beginning.
And I'd like to unpack
a little bit what
the promise of
serverless really is.
What do we see it as?
Now at Google we like
to joke that serverless
is about no servers.
And, obviously, there are still
servers running a data center
somewhere.
But it's about making
sure that developers
don't have to be concerned
with what those servers are,
what that infrastructure
that underlies
your application really is.
If you want to bring a
container, deploy a function,
or just an
application, you should
be able to do that regardless of
what the underlying platform is
that it will run on.
It also means being idiomatic,
which is another Google-ism,
I think--
which is really to say that it's
native to you as a developer.
It's meeting the
developers where they are.
So if you're a Go
developer, you should just
be able to be a Go developer.
You shouldn't have to learn a
bunch of quirks in our system.
If you want to be a
Node.js developer,
just be an Node.js developer.
Don't worry about how to
integrate with the platform.
And then the third promise
is about being event-driven.
Today, if you want to wire up
a bunch of different systems,
you typically end up hard-coding
those systems together,
putting all of that
logic into your code,
instead of being able to
declaratively bind things
through in a venting framework.
And we at Google see
one more promise here,
which is that serverless
really should be keeping
you free of vendor lock-in.
By adopting the
promise of serverless,
you should be able
to take your code
and run it wherever you feel
most appropriate, if that's
an on-premises data center,
a third-party data center,
or in the cloud.
You shouldn't have to choose.
You should be able to
keep using the framework
that you're using.
So Kubernetes and serverless,
if you think about it,
are kind of two sides of the
same pursuit, two things that
go great together, like
chocolate and peanut butter--
unless you happen to be
allergic to chocolate or peanut
butter and then it's
absolutely nothing like that.
But what Kubernetes
does for the operator,
hiding away all of the
sort of complexities
of the underlying
infrastructure that you're
running on and allowing
the smooth, paved surface,
serverless does for
developers, allowing
them to not be concerned about
the platform they're running on
and just focus on the core
value of the code that matters.
And, in fact, we at
Google believe in this
so strongly that this
is the future of the way
that compute should be
run, that this morning we
were happy to announce the GKE
serverless add-on, which brings
all of the wonderful operator
friendliness of Kubernetes
and all of the developer
friendliness of serverless
together into our
Google Cloud Platform.
So the benefits of using
the serverless add-on--
number one, it's easy to start
deploying with less code.
Today, if you want to deploy
an application on Kubernetes,
you have to deal with a
bunch of configuration.
You have to write all
of that and check it in.
The serverless add-on makes
this much, much simpler.
And I'll show you
how in a little bit.
It also makes it easy to run
a serverless-style workload,
being able to go from source all
the way to a deployed container
with a URL in minutes.
It automatically deals with all
the network programming, all
of the provisioning ingress,
and all of the different layers
inside Kubernetes that you used
to have to deal with before.
And it helps auto-scaling.
And you might be
telling yourself,
hey, Kubernetes
already auto-scales.
Why is he talking
about this in context
of the serverless add-on?
And you're right--
Kubernetes does scale.
But the serverless add-on
makes it scale better.
And it makes it scale in a way
that Kubernetes doesn't today.
We can actually
scale your workload
all the way down
to 0, which lets
an operator in your company
pack more applications
into the same cluster resources
and have everything continue
to run really well.
So, now that we've introduced
the serverless add-on,
let's actually show
it to you in action.
If we can switch over to my
laptop, I'll be very happy.
Good.
So the very first thing
that we need to do
is stand up a cluster with the
serverless add-on installed.
And this is an alpha that
we're talking about today.
So you'll see I'm using the
alpha parameter in G Cloud.
But we're just going to
go create a new cluster
and enable the
serverless add-on.
And, you know, let's
see if this works.
Aha, there we go.
So I got a couple of
warnings about defaults
that are changing.
But that's fine.
Meanwhile, I'm going to
go switch over and use
a cluster that already
exists so that I don't have
to sit here and watch
that little thing
spin for a second or two.
I always like to get
started with a new platform
by taking a look
at a Hello World.
So I have a simple
Hello World application
that I've written in Go.
It really doesn't get
any simpler than this.
If you can come up with
a simpler Hello World,
let me know.
And then I heard a dockerfile,
because the way that this works
today in alpha is
that it requires
me to have a dockerfile
and deploy a container.
So this is just a very
idiomatic or native dockerfile.
In fact, I just searched
for a dockerfile for Go lang
and got this and used it.
So how easy is it for me to
deploy this on my own box.
It's idiomatic.
I should be able to test
it and run it here, right?
So if you're
familiar with Docker,
I can just do docker build.
And I'll tag it with
a particular container
repository.
So it's going to go
do a little build.
It's going to produce
a container for me.
This went a lot
faster in rehearsal.
There we go.
And I'll just run that container
real quick so that you can
see what this application does.
You'll see it outputs
a little bit of log.
And if I go here--
uh-oh-- you guys should have
caught what I did wrong.
Come on.
I need to expose
the port in Docker
to make sure that
this actually works.
All right.
So there, very simple.
Just Hello World,
welcome to GCP Next.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Hey, it works.
Man, if I could get you
guys applauding at the fact
that I took a Go app and
built it in Docker, I am set.
This is good.
OK.
But now let's do the same
thing and actually run
this in my serverless
add-on cluster.
So I'm going to run the G
Cloud serverless command.
And I'm going to say I
want to deploy a service.
And I'm going to specify
the image that I built.
And if you're paying
attention, you'll
notice I didn't push this.
But that's just to save time.
I pushed this image earlier.
So G Cloud's going
to ask me, what
do I want to name this service.
And it provides a nice
suggestion of Hello World.
I'll take it.
And now it's going
to go out and do
all of the lightweight
provisioning that's
required to stand this up
inside the serverless add-on.
And, hopefully, this
doesn't take too long.
Because, again, in rehearsal,
it went really fast.
Done.
Cool.
All right.
So now I have a URL, which is
actually out there and live.
And if I hit this,
you'll see, hey,
there's the same sample running
out of my Kubernetes cluster.
[APPLAUSE]
And, you'll notice,
I didn't have
to deal with anything
in Kubernetes.
I didn't use kube-cuddle.
I didn't create a manifest.
I don't look at YAML.
But let's actually go look at
the YAML and see what happened.
So the serverless add-on
installs a few CRDs
that make all of this possible.
The first one I'm gonna
look at is the service CRD.
So I'm going to kubectl get
service.serving.native.dev.
If you have feedback on
the name, go to GitHub.
So what this is going to do--
when it finally loads--
all right.
There is just my
Hello World sample.
I'm going to dump the
YAML real quick just
to show you that there's
actually YAML behind it
and point out a couple things.
There's a bunch of
status conditions
on how the service has changed.
But, simply, here's the
spec that it got created.
So it defined a
concurrency model for me,
that my container supports
multi-concurrency.
And it just points at
the container image--
really, really simple thing.
And it has the domain for
where I'm being served from
and the revision.
So what's a revision?
Well, the revision is actually
another one of the CRDs
that we published.
And revision is the immutable
state of my application.
So it's tying all of the
configuration details
and the actual
container image together
into an object inside
Kubernetes that describes it.
And, as I continue
to make changes,
it continues to
snap new revisions.
So it's easy to roll
back or to split traffic
between multiple
revisions or deal
with these sort of multiple
deployments that you want to.
And then the last
object that I'm
going to show you is the route.
And what the route does is it is
another CRD that just connects
between the outside world
and the revision that's
running inside my container.
In this case, it's
using HTTP to route
from that Hello World
domain that was published
to the particular revision.
And it's always pointing at
the latest revision by default.
But if I wanted to point
out a particular revision,
I could do that as well.
All right.
Let's do a little bit
more advanced sample.
So this time around, I have
written an actual guestbook
where you can post a message and
see it online using cloud data
store as the back end.
And it just exposes
two little APIs
in a very Go-friendly
style of doing that.
And it serves some static
content using the HTTP file
server object.
But this time around I'm
going to pretend that I
don't have Docker installed.
And I'm going to say,
hey, I have this code.
How do I actually go
about building that code
and having it run
on the service?
So, again, I create a Docker
file, a very simple one that
installs some dependencies.
And this time around I am going
to get in and build some YAML.
So I'm going to define a
service, like G Cloud did
for me automatically.
And I'm going to
say that my source
code comes from this
particular Git repository.
And I want to use
the master branch.
And then I'm going to use the
kaniko build template that's
baked into the
serverless add-on,
and have it build
that code for me,
and push it into this
container registry.
And then I want it to deploy
that container into my code.
And so I'm going to
do kubectl apply.
And if I go out and
get my pods, you'll
see there's this new pod
that isn't a deployment pod.
That's actually the
build pod spinning up.
And I'm going to go out and take
a look at Stackdriver, where,
of course, because this is
integratedly Google Cloud,
Stackdriver is automatically
plumbed through as well.
So I can see what's going on.
And I'm going to search
for build in my logs.
Hopefully, I'll
see the right logs.
Maybe I'm not streaming.
That's why.
There we go.
All right.
So here's a bunch
of build output.
And you'll see it actually
ended up pushing the container.
Now ignore the fact
that everything shows up
as a warning.
Like I said, this is an alpha.
There's a few
quirks to work out.
That might be one of them.
All right.
If I go back here and
get my pods again.
The build is done.
You'll actually see I
now have a deployment.
And I can go to my
guestbook application.
And, if everything
works right, I
should see some
guestbook entries here.
Oh, that's not what
I wanted to see.
Oh, all right, I see what I--
I jumped the gun.
It wasn't actually running.
Now it's running.
Let's try it again.
There we go.
Now it actually works.
[APPLAUSE]
And just to prove it,
I'll post something
and you'll see it show up.
Cool.
Now, that's neat.
Let's see what happens if I
actually throw some load at it.
So, in this window, I'm
going to use watch--
kubectl get pods.
And you'll see right
now I have a Hello World
pod and a guest book pod.
And I'm going to run
a little script that's
going to throw 10 queries--
or 10 threads and 250
queries at this thing.
And you'll see that the
serverless add-on is responding
to the load by scaling out the
containers that I have here.
And it's going to make sure
that all of those requests
are satisfied as fast as
possible by spinning up
as much capacity as it
can inside my cluster.
[APPLAUSE]
So that's really exciting.
The last part of this demo
that I was hoping-- yep,
there it goes.
So you see the Hello World demo
is now actually spinning down.
That pod is terminating
because nobody in the audience
actually went to that URL.
And so it's timed out.
It's hit the time-out limit.
And now that pod is
going to go away.
And so you can see it's
actually saving me resources
inside my pod, or
inside my cluster,
rather, because of that.
So this is just a really
brief introduction to what
the serverless add-on can do.
There's so much
more baked in here.
And we're going to tell you
a little bit more today.
But tomorrow, at
the same time slot,
actually, is a very
deep, technical deep-dive
into the underlying
technology on this
that you should come to.
And you can learn all about
all of the intricate details
in here.
OK.
If we can switch
back to the slides--
cool.
So just to recap the
demo really quickly--
we went on and we turned on a
cluster inside Kubernetes that
deployed the serverless add-on.
So I didn't have to load a
bunch of manifests or anything
to get all this stuff installed.
It was just there by
default inside my cluster--
or there when I enabled
the add-on rather.
We then deployed
a Hello World app
from a container using
the G Cloud command
line to make it really easy.
And then we built
source actually
on the cluster, safely
contained inside the cluster.
So nothing had to leave
my cluster by doing that.
And then we showed how
it scaled up and down.
And then, events is
another big piece of this.
And, like I said, I didn't
have time in this demo
to show off events.
But come tomorrow and
we'll talk about how events
work inside this space as well.
But it's great
for me from Google
to stand up here and tell you
how awesome my technology is.
But you shouldn't just
take my word for this.
So I'd like to invite
Ram from T-Mobile up.
He's the principal
technology architect
to tell you a little
bit more about how
T-Mobile has been
using the technology
inside the serverless add-on.
RAM GOPINATHAN: Thank you, Ryan.
RYAN GREGG: Thank you, Ram.
[APPLAUSE]
RAM GOPINATHAN: Thank you Ryan
and DeWitt for having me here.
First of all, huge
congrats on the milestone.
So we're really-- from all of
us at T-Mobile, huge congrats
to you guys.
So choice of running the
workloads in different clouds
is important for us.
So when the Google
team asked us to test
drive the serverless add-on,
we couldn't be more excited.
So what I want to do in
this next couple of slides
is talk about a use case
that we picked to run--
to test drive the
serverless add-on.
So, basically what
you're seeing here
is, we have this experience
called store locator.
Pretty much as you
can guess, this
is used by our customers to
see what stores are nearby,
so they can call the store
or even get directions
so they can go out to the
store and buy services.
So just to tell you a little
bit about the service that's
in production today--
it's basically a
Java application
that is containerized and
running in our Mesos marathon
container platform.
Not only we had to
build the service,
we also had to write code
to actually collect metrics,
send the metrics to a
time series database.
Scaling is largely manual
because we get alerts
from Grafana and then we create
dashboards to actually monitor.
And then, when there's
alerts kicking in,
we go and manually scale it.
The other part is
it's always running.
Even when the
service is not used
it's always running, which
means it's taking resources
from the cluster.
So, if it's not used, why
take resources, right?
You could use it for other
workloads, as, I think,
Ryan had talked
about previously.
The last bit here is there's
a lot of investment that's
gone into CI/CD to get
proper pipeline wired up,
to go from dev all the
way into production.
So we thought this
was a great use case
because it's not like always--
people are not always using it--
usually when you have
to go to a store.
So it fits perfectly
for server scenarios.
So what did we do?
We basically ported the
existing code, which
is a big Java application.
We ported that, just the logic
required-- the business logic--
into Go lang functions.
And, because we were
building it on top
of the serverless
add-on, we didn't really
have to worry about
creating the metrics,
sending the metrics to a time
series database, and whatnot.
We didn't have to worry
about log collection.
about scaling, auto scaling.
And our devs just had to focus
on just bringing the business
logic over.
We finished this project in
literally a two-week sprint,
which was kind of cool.
Getting a little bit deeper
into the architecture here--
so as you can see
from this slide,
we basically took the
business logic code
and split it into two functions.
One is the indexing
piece, indexer function.
What that does is it
takes the store data
and puts it into an
Elasticsearch index.
Because the serverless add-on
is built on top of Kubernetes,
we were able to deploy a
production-grade Elasticsearch
cluster into our same
infrastructure with a helm
chart.
So that's pretty easy.
And then the other
function you see
here is the query
function, which
takes the request from
the app and executes
a geo-distance search queries
against the Elasticsearch
and shows you the results.
So pretty straightforward.
Now I want to talk a little bit
about where are going with it.
So today we have,
as I said earlier,
we have store data
in different sources.
We want to actually kind
of create, basically,
a BigQuery dataset and
have all of the store
data in a central location.
And then when the store data
changes, based on those events,
we want the index to be
automatically updated
so that our customers are always
seeing the most current data.
And then T-Mobile's
pretty heavy into--
supportive of open source.
So we want to open
source the store data set
so that other people or other
developers in the industry
can actually build
something that we
didn't imagine or experience.
So we want to open
source the data set.
We also want to open
source the function code
because Store
Locator is something
that pretty much
every retailer has,
the same kind of lead, right?
If you look at Best Buy
or different applications,
the Store Locator is
something we see everywhere.
So we want to open
source that as well.
And then the last bit
here is we're always
looking for ways to improve the
experience for our customer,
make it easy.
So we want to integrate
with Google Assistant
so that it gives a natural
language kind of interaction
with the experience.
I think that's about it.
[APPLAUSE]
So hopefully this was useful.
Thanks.
Thanks, Ram.
It's been a pleasure working
with you and the T-Mobile team.
And we really
appreciate your passion
around the serverless technology
that we're building here
and where we're going
to go in the future.
And I can't wait to see where
you guys take this stuff too.
So that's the GKE
serverless add-on.
Like I said, it's available
in an alpha program right now.
If you would like to
request access to that,
please check out this URL.
It'll be available for
everybody later this year.
But, you know, there's a lot
of time left in this talk.
Huh.
T-Mobile talked a lot
about open source too.
That might be a good idea.
What do you think?
DEWITT CLINTON: Maybe we
should talk a little bit more
about that.
RYAN GREGG: All right.
DEWITT CLINTON: Thank you, Ryan.
Thank you, Ram.
So as we were building the
serverless add-on for GKE
and working with
customers like T-Mobile,
we had the opportunity
to survey the space.
And we realized
that the marriage
of serverless and Kubernetes is
attracting a lot of interest.
And, rather than
shy away from that,
we saw it as a
perfect opportunity
to bring everybody
together to collaborate.
And that's what we're
going to talk about now.
I'm very pleased
to introduce today
Knative, which
provides the building
blocks for running serverless
workloads on Kubernetes.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And what I'm going to show
you should look familiar
because Ryan just showed
it to you in the demo.
This is real
technology that we're
deploying into our real
clusters and supporting.
And we believe
that's the right way
to approach an
open-source problem.
But you don't do it alone.
Doing this right
requires an ecosystem.
And we are very proud to have
worked with some of the biggest
and leading names in
cloud, like Pivotal and SAP
and Red Hat and IBM to codify
the commonalities for running
serverless on Kubernetes.
And we're going to hear
from some of them today.
Before I get started, though, I
want to show you the landscape
and show you where
in the overall stack
we think that Knative fits in.
So we start first
with Kubernetes,
the universal platform.
It's ubiquitous.
It runs everywhere.
We take that for granted.
And that's what allows us
to do this, which is build
a layer of building blocks--
these primitive components--
for essential operations
for running serverless
workloads on top of Kubernetes.
We're starting with Build
and Serving and Eventing.
But this is just
the beginning and we
expect it to grow from here.
In fact, I've
heard this referred
to as the standard library
for running serverless
on Kubernetes.
And I think I'm OK
with that analogy.
And here we see the
type of products
that we envision being
built on top of Knative.
Google is sharing a few of
those with the world today.
Earlier today we learned about
SAP's Kyma, Pivotal's function
service.
And we'll talk about those now.
Again, I can't emphasize enough,
so I added a whole other slide
just to say it.
This is not a
science fair project.
This is not a 20% open source
project that we're shipping.
Rather, it's Google
products that we
are taking the open source
out of and giving away.
And we're not doing it alone.
Earlier today, SAP
announced SAP Kyma,
which is based on Knative
serverless components.
They say that
Knative will further
enable SAP to accelerate
enterprise serverless
and event-based applications.
SAP has been an incredible
development partner throughout
and I'm really excited about
what's going on with Kyma.
They're around this
week at the SAP booth
and I hope that
everybody gets a chance
to stop by and see what
we're doing with Kyma.
And IBM cloud is
investing in Knative.
IBM, of course, has extensive
background and experience
running serverless workloads
at scale with OpenWhisk.
And we are working
together, and they
are leading, and bringing
their leadership and expertise
to help bring serverless to a
wider range of applications,
developers, and industry
than ever before.
And Red Hat, who's been focused
on open source and customer
choice since the beginning,
is investing in Knative
to create a common
building block
for serverless on
top of Kubernetes
across the hybrid cloud.
Absolutely wonderful
working with Red Hat.
Very excited to see this in the
open shift function service.
And T-Mobile isn't
just a customer.
T-Mobile is also a
contributor to Knative.
With their Jazz framework
they are integrating Knative
into the very fabric
that T-Mobile runs on.
Knative and Kubernetes and
Jazz are working beautifully
together to accelerate
T-Mobile's move
to cloud-native applications.
Been fantastic working with
a partner and a customer who
has so much to add in the
open-source world as well.
Thank you, Ram.
In fact, this is the beginning.
Maybe the future
of serverless is
going to be built on
Kubernetes and Knative.
Some of you know Sebastien,
creator of Kubeless.
He says that Knative
is standardizing
the primitives needed
to simplify code
to production workflows.
It promises to be
a solid foundation
to develop the future
of serverless computing.
It's been amazing
having Seb help out.
So thank you.
And you've heard me talk a lot.
Now I would like to
bring up my friend Ryan
Morgan, Vice President of
Application Platform at Pivotal
Software, who's done more
for Knative than anybody.
Thank you, Ryan.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN MORGAN: Thank you, DeWitt.
It's been fantastic working
with you and the team.
And I'm excited
to share with you
our experience around Knative
and where we see it going.
But, first, why serverless?
I think, judging by the
number of hands I saw early,
maybe I don't need
to explain this.
But at Pivotal our mission
is to transform the way
the world builds software.
Part of that is being able
to deliver the right compute
abstractions on the cloud of
your choice for your workload.
The top thing on
there, for functions--
we view that as a really
important enterprise use case.
And it's an area that we've
been invested in fairly heavily.
And that's a problem that we
want to solve for our customers
today.
Then why Knative?
About a year ago,
Pivotal partnered
with VMware and Google to
bring Pivotal container service
to market.
Pivotal container service was
a enterprise-grade Kubernetes
distribution that's
deployable to vSphere
and has the promise of constant
compatibility with GKE.
We view Kubernetes
as a great platform
for building platforms.
And, from that, we
started Project Riff.
Project Riff had the
top goals of being
k8s native with a focus on
event streaming and first class
support for Spring
and for Java, but also
for other languages as well.
One thing we've seen
is when you reduce
the scope of concern
for developers,
it allows them to
be more productive.
As the stewards of
the Spring framework,
we've seen this with Spring
Boot and Functions just
takes that one step further.
But as we were developing
Riff, we quickly
realized that there are
some missing pieces.
There's a lot about
container builds,
things about incremental
deploys, auto scaling,
and things that we
weren't concerned
with at the beginning.
And, at this point,
we were introduced
to DeWitt and his team
working on Knative.
And we realized that
Riff and Knative
were very complimentary, that
things that we were working on
really fit in well with the
plans they had for Knative.
So we began working with Google
to contribute some of our code
into the Knative project.
And through that we then rebased
the Riff developer experience
for event-driven
functions onto Knative.
So, really, we're betting
our future on Knative.
And part of that is our
first release today.
So this morning at 9:30, we
released our first version
of Riff, that is fully
built on top of Knative.
I also wanted to go into
a few of the contributions
that we've made to date.
The first is around the Riff
build, the build templates that
are provided within Knative.
Through our experience
in Cloud Foundry,
we have a lot of experience
with build packs.
Build packs offer the ability
to just push your code
and from that generate an
image that's then runnable.
Build packs are
very easy to write
and there's been
quite a bit of success
with build packs
in the FaaS world,
and we're very
excited to see what
that might bring to Knative.
The second is around Riff and
the topics and the eventing
that we were working on there
and the contribution of that
into the channel
abstraction within Knative.
What that does is it provides
not only functions but also
applications with the ability
to publish and receive
streams of events for
event-based functions.
If you follow Pivotal,
you might hear
us talk about the value line.
The value line is the
point in your architecture
where changes below that
line are not delivering value
to your end customers.
We feel that that concept
applies in open source as well.
And, in this case,
the building blocks
that Knative provide
on top of Kubernetes
allows you as developers to
worry less about infrastructure
and focus more on your code.
So for Pivotal this all means--
this really comes down to a new
product called Pivotal Function
Service.
This will be deployable and
runnable on Pivotal Container
Service and will provide a
common Function abstraction
across any cloud or on premise.
It will have strong support
for Java and for Spring,
but also will support
other languages as well.
And, like all Pivotal
products, will
have a strong focus on Day 2.
And, most importantly,
these are all
built upon components that
are built within Knative.
So this is all very new.
This is obviously day one.
But we're very excited
about the future of Knative
and look forward to working
with you all in the community.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DEWITT CLINTON: Thank you, Ryan.
Thank you.
I can honestly say
that we would not
be here without the help and
support and contributions
of Pivotal.
It's been fantastic working
with Ryan and the team.
I'm really excited about
the future for Riff.
I'm excited about the
future for Knative
based on the things we've
learned in that collaboration.
Really been fantastic.
So thank you, Ryan.
Now I'm going to tell
you, at very high level--
so this is very low fidelity--
a little bit about what
is in Knative today.
This is early on and we're
just getting started.
And I'm not going to go
into a lot of detail,
because tomorrow there's
a technical talk, DEV209,
where the tech leads will go and
unpack this a little bit more.
So right now it focuses
on the common components
that everybody needs,
below the value line,
where you want to codify the
commonalities, where you're not
deriving proprietary
business logic,
but rather something
that's better off if we all
get it right.
OK?
So right now we're starting with
Build and Serving and Events.
So what does Build provide?
As you know, containers
are the lingua franca--
the common language--
of Kubernetes.
And they're the common
language of Knative as well.
But if you're a developer like
me, you don't write containers.
You write code.
So you need something
that's going
to allow you to orchestrate
the process of going
from code to container.
And what Knative
build primitives
do is allow you to describe that
in such a way that maybe safely
on cluster with Conoco, or in
the cloud with Google Cloud
build, you can have your
Kubernetes work flow pull
that code into a container.
But when you have a container,
what do you do with it?
You want to serve it.
So what Knative
serving components do
is allow you to describe
your workload in a way that
makes sense for the developer.
You saw some of these
in Ryan's demo--
the route and the
configuration, the sort
of 12-factor app
style of development
that we've learned building
serverless products at Google.
And that will allow the
system to do things for you,
like scale it from 0
to 1, or 1 to 100,000,
or maybe even better,
100,000 back down to 0 again.
So that's the type
of things that
having these standard
primitives allow you to do.
And that's great.
Makes a wonderful
day one experience.
But what about day
two, day five, day 100,
when you're still trying
to run these workloads
in real production?
Then you need
something that's smart
about blue-green deployments
and traffic shifting.
And those are the
other components
that are inside native serving.
And you might want to serve
these over HTTP or HTTPS.
That's great.
You can do that--
set up an ingress
rule, set up a route.
But you may also want to attach
it to a larger event ecosystem.
You may want to attach it to a
Git commit or something being
flowed off your CI/CD pipeline.
And what the Knative
eventing primitives do
is allow you to describe,
in a developer-friendly way,
the binding from event
producer to event consumer
and provide the
underlying infrastructure
to make that happen.
So I showed you
what's in the box.
Let's talk a little bit about
why we made those choices
and how it got in the box.
So there are some
core principles
that the development team uses.
The first is, it
should be idiomatic.
And by that I mean--
let's take, for
example, Kubernetes.
If Kubernetes has a
way of doing things,
if it has a standard, native
way, we'll do it that way.
We won't reinvent the
wheel with Knative.
It should layer
naturally on top.
You saw the kube-cuddle demo,
where the exact same command
line works against
Knative as well.
And, also, we shouldn't have you
get a PhD in Knative to use it.
We should meet
you where you are.
If you're a node developer,
who writes Docker files,
we should be able to take your
existing idiomatic node code,
and your existing
idiomatic Docker files,
and run them and serve them
with all the advantages
that you would get.
Second, it should be extensible.
I showed you these layers
of loose coupling--
Build and Serving and Events.
And you should be able
to, in your products,
pick and choose among them.
You may want Build.
You may want all three.
But it also should be
pluggable at the bottom.
We saw a demo where it was
wired into Stackdriver.
You should be able to pull that
out and put in an Oak stack,
do whatever you need.
So we should make it
extensible at the top
but pluggable at the bottom.
And then, lastly-- and I sort
of struggled to find the right
word for this--
but it should feel organic.
And by that I really mean we
should start from the bottoms
up and codify the commonalities,
the stuff that we all
agree on that need to be there.
We shouldn't be inventing
new things that feel rough.
We should do the things
that you want in order
to have a stable platform for
the developers in your org.
So let's talk about
those developers.
Many of us in this
room are that persona.
We write code all day.
And that's what we should
be doing for our businesses.
These APIs are designed
for developers.
They're designed to make
a developer's life easier.
They are designed to provide
a serverless experience
on top of Kubernetes.
But how do they get that system?
Operators.
Operators provide these
systems to developers.
In fact, you met an
operator earlier today--
Ryan-- who's operating the
serverless add-on for GKE.
And your organization
may have teams
of operators who are
deploying these things
for your businesses.
And maybe all of us--
hopefully all of us--
will also be contributors,
that this is something
that we all want to work on
together to get it right.
And we strongly believe in
the power of open source
to do this.
So why is Google
investing in it?
Why are we doing it?
It's clearly not easy.
Frankly, we're doing it
because you asked us to.
You're moving your
businesses to Kubernetes.
But you don't want to
leave serverless behind.
You want to bring
serverless with you.
So Google is responding
by helping out
by building serverless
on top of Kubernetes.
Then you asked, why are we
doing it in open source?
Well, you also want
workload portability.
You want the freedom of choice
to run wherever you want,
in your data center or in ours.
And we want to help provide
that through open source.
So, to recap--
Knative is providing
those building blocks
for running serverless
on Kubernetes.
And today we're starting with
Build and Serving and Events.
It's very early days
and we expect it
to grow rather big from here.
And we're doing this so you can
run wherever you want to run.
Wherever you can
run Kubernetes, we
think you should be able to
run your serverless workloads.
And we're very pleased to be
doing this, not on our own,
but with a very broad
community of industry partners.
And, best of all-- and I've
been waiting to say this
for a really long time--
Knative is open today.
You can go to GitHub.
I put this slide last
so you wouldn't all
go at the beginning of the talk.
But go to GitHub.com/knative
and get involved.
We're really excited
to open it today.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN GREGG: Thanks, DeWitt.
So that was amazing.
I can't wait to get
started with Knative.
DEWITT CLINTON: Thanks.
RYAN GREGG: Oh, wait.
I already did get
started with Knative.
If you want to get started
using this technology today,
please go out and sign up for
early access to the serverless
add-on.
I will be sending out invites
when I get back from Next
and we have everything
ready to go.
And, of course, you can go
learn more about Knative today
at that URL and go check
out the GitHub repository.
DEWITT CLINTON: And you can
install right to any Kubernetes
cluster.
In fact, somebody submitted a
pull request in the last four
hours that shows how to do
yet another install flow
on a Kubernetes.
So super exciting.
Everybody is already
getting involved.
RYAN GREGG: And, of course,
this isn't only talk about this
while we're here.
Please check out
tomorrow, especially
at 4:35, the DEV209 talk
with Ville and Mark,
who are hanging out
back there, to learn
all the technical
details-- well,
some more of the technical
details-- behind Knative,
as well as a number of
other of serverless talks
about where Google is going
with serverless today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]